[Musique]
il est très sérieusement question de les
traquer de les sanctionner de les
chasser qui les amoureux de paris ceux
qui trop souvent se donne en spectacle
se croyant seul au monde il paraît
qu'ils ont pu ce que les passants bref
les pères la pudeur ne veulent plus les
voir ils parlent même de les traîner sur
d'autres dans vingt familles cela qu'ils
ont d'interdire les bancs publics aux
amoureux qu'est ce que vous en pensez
on sait je suis pas beaucoup les
journaux c'est pas tellement courant on
peut pas toujours le cinéma est ce que
vous en pensez
bah
chez un petit peu surpris parce que moi
je trouve qu'on est vraiment bien là
puis elle grand air et puis enlever les
bancs publics aux amoureux c'est idiot
voilà on l'a toujours fait ça nos
parents l'ont bien fait il ya aucune
raison qu'on nous en priver moi je
trouve tout un débat public on aimerait
qu'il n'y aurait pas eu ce fait est
jamais mariés là les amoureux d'amour et
moi je suis comme quoi y'a pas toi même
place
les amoureux qui se bécotent sur les
bancs publics bancs publics bancs
publics en foutant pas mary okach
oblique des passants honnêtes les
amoureux qui se bécotent sur les bancs
publics bancs publics d'un public en
visant des je t'aime ma technique
on aime bien ça
[Musique]